GOOD AFTERNOON MORNING
STILL MOURNING SO MORNING
WELCOME TO JUDICIARY FOR
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH
THIS IS OUR LAST HEARING BEFORE
THE FISCAL DEADLINE SO WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE- OF ALL
THE BILLS WE POSSIBLY CAN WE'RE
GONNA START TODAY WITH OUR ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY EIGHTY.
WOOD AND I WILL NOTE THAT WE OF
COURSE ARE STILL IN A BIT OF THE
PANDEMIC INFO MASKS AND-
PHYSICAL DISTANCING ARE NOT.
REQUIRED WERE ASKING IF PEOPLE
STILL BE SAFE AND WE ENCOURAGE
MASKS WHEN POSSIBLE END. TO
CONDUCT OURSELVES IN PHYSICALLY
SAFE MANNER SO THAT WE ARE NOT
SPREADING THE DISEASE ANY
FURTHER THAN S. NECESSARY WE
WILL BE HAVING WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AS WELL AS ON THE
PHONE. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF
YOU'RE WANTING THE COMMENTS YOU
CAN SO WITNESSES CAN COME TO THE
DÍAS OR TO THE DESKS AND THAT
WAS THE PUBLIC CAN COMMENT AT
THE MICROPHONE WE ASK THAT
PEOPLE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AND FOR CALL IN. THE
PUBLIC- FREE NUMBERS.
877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN THAT NUMBER
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN AND IT
IS ALSO ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THERE IS A PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. SO THAT
SOME OF THE LOGISTICS FOR TOAY
WE WILL START A A SUBCOMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET A
QUORUM. RELATIVELY SOON AND MR
SANTIAGO IS CHAIRING HIS
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT SO WILL
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO GET HIS
COMMITTEE DONE AND THIS THIS ONE
DONE AS WELL. SERVICE TO IT AB
TWENTY EIGHTY WELCOME THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH
THE WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND THE
ASSAULT THANK YOU FOR THE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AT ODDS. IT
WAS A GOOD READ. I HAVE MADE.
IMPROVING ACCESS AND CAN ONLY GO
TO CIRCUS WOULD I'M NOT SURE I
DON'T THINK WE'RE ON. NO I DON'T
THINK YOU ARE ON THAT THE
BUTTONS ARE CORRECT. BUT I'M
STILL NOT I'M NOT HEARING YOU
ALTHOUGH IT'S HARD TO LOWER FROM
UP HERE HELLO. NO I DON'T THINK
I'LL EVER SEE PICS OF BETTER
THAN THAT. IT'S ON- IT'S ON YEAH
IT'S OKAY I WOULD JUST WASN'T
HEARING IT SORRY GO AHEAD OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL START
OVER- THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU OKAY. K. POP UP
WINDOWS INSTEAD THAT'S- FINE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR. FOR WORKING WITH ME
ON THIS BILL AND THE CONSULTANT
THANK YOU FOR THE EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS IT WAS A GOOD READ. OP
I'VE MADE ACCESS OF IMPROVING
ACCESS AND QUALITY TO HEALTH
CARE AND- CONTAINING THE COSTS
OF HEALTH CARE ONE OF MY TOP
PRIORITIES. THIS BILL IS NO
DIFFERENT. CONSOLIDATION IN
HEALTH CARE HAS NOT PROVEN TO
INCREASE EFFICIENCIES AND
QUALITY NOR CONTAIN COSTS. THIS
BILL PROHIBITS SIX TYPES OF ANTI
COMPETITIVE CONTRACT PROVISIONS
INTO HOSPITALS BUT ALSO TO
HEALTH PLANS INSURERS AND HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL HODIERNA SARAH FILE
FILED A CIVIL ANTITRUST ACTION
UNDER THE CART RIGHT ACT AGAINST
THE SUTTER HEALTH HOSPITAL
SYSTEM IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AFTER YEARS OF LITIGATION
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SPENT THE
AGE SHE WAS SUCCESSFUL.
RESULTING IN A FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SETTLEMENT AN AGREEMENT BY
SUTTER TO CHANGE A NUMBER OF ITS
ANTI COMPETITIVE PRACTICES. HAVE
THIS LEGISLATION YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY BEEN IN PLACE THERE'S A
GOOD VERY GOOD CHANCE WE COULD
HAVE PREVENTED YEARS OF ANTI
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR. AND COST
TO PATIENTS NOT TO MENTION THE
TIME AND MONEY SPENT ON THE
LITIGATION. AB TWENTY EIGHTY
WOULD SIMPLY CODIFY THE CHANGES
MADE BY THE CENTER SETTLEMENT
BOTH INDUSTRY WIDE AND
STATEWIDE. NO ONE IS SAYING THAT
EVERY CONSOLIDATION IS BAD. BUT
THE SEPARATE LITIGATION TOOK US
THROUGH THE COMPREHENSIVE
PROCESS THAT THE AG COULD USE TO
LOOK AT PENDING CONSOLIDATIONS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY WOULD ALSO
BENEFIT HEALTH CARE CONSUMERS
NOT SOLELY CORPORATE PROFITS.
NATIONAL HEALTHCARE SPENDING IS
PROJECTED TO GROW AT AN AVERAGE
ANNUAL RATE OF FIVE POINT 4% FOR
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY EIGHT. MUCH
FASTER THAN THE AT THE AVERAGE
ANNUAL AND PRE PANDEMIC GROWTH
OF FOUR POINT 2% FROM TWENTY TEN
TO TWENTY NINETEEN. THE INDUSTRY
ARGUES THAT CONSOLIDATION
IMPROVES QUALITY. BUT THEIR
ARGUMENT IS ONLY SUPPORTED BY
INDUSTRY SPONSORED STUDIES. THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY SMALL
BUSINESS CAN BUSINESSES
CONSUMERS HEALTH CARE ADVOCATES
AND LABOR. AND OPPOSED BY THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE
EXPERIENCES REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT
. THE CONSOLIDATION RESULTS IN
BENEFITS TO HEALTHCARE CONSUMERS
THE OPPOSITION NEED NOT BE
CONCERNED. THAT IT PUSHES THE
ORGANIZATIONS THEY WANT TO
CONSOLIDATE TO KEEP THOSE
CONSUMERS IN MIND AS WELL WE'RE
ALL BETTER OFF FOR ME. PLEASE
I'D LIKE TO HEAR YOU TO HEAR
FROM MY WITNESSES- WITH US TODAY
BETH CAPELL WITH HEALTH ACCESS.
AND JENNA SO MELLIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
THANK YOU AND MISS WOULD BEFORE
WE GO TO. THE WITNESSES THEIR
AMENDMENTS LISTED STARTING ON
PAGE TEN YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
AUTHORS OF ADMINS YES SIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE BETH BELL AND
THEY HAVE HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION FOR
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
SUPPORTED BE TWENTY EIGHTY
BECAUSE WE KNOW FROM AN APPLE
ACADEMIC LITERATURE THE
CONSOLIDATION DRIVES UP COSTS.
WITHOUT IMPROVING QUALITY AND
SOMETIMES EVEN WORSE SINCE
MORTALITY OR DEATH RATES. THE
ONLY STUDIES THAT SHOW
DIFFERENTLY OR THOSE FUNDED BY
THE HOSPITAL INDUSTRY ITSELF. WE
KNOW FROM THIRTY YEARS OF
WORKING WITH ATTORNEYS GENERAL
OF BOTH PARTIES. ON NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL MERGERS THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACTION IN CALIFORNIA HAS
KEPT HOSPITALS OPEN. UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA PROTECTED EMERGENCY
ROOMS LABOR AND LABOR DELIVERY
CARDIAC CARE REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES AND MORE. IN MORE
RECENT YEARS ATTORNEYS GENERAL
HAVE IMPOSED CONDITIONS TO
PREVENT ANTI COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIOR SIMILAR TO WHAT SUTTER
OF HIS ALLEGED TO HAVE ENGAGED
IN AN TO MODERATE POST
CONSOLIDATION PRICE INCREASES.
FOR OVER A CENTURY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. GENERAL IN CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD THE AUTHORITY TO
INTERVENE TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AGAINST ANTI COMPETITIVE
PRACTICES THE SOUTHERLY TO GET
ASIAN IS EIGHT ONE OF THE MORE
RECENT EXAMPLES OF THAT. YOU
WILL HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL REVIEW
MAKES BUSINESS DECISIONS MORE
EXPENSIVE AND TIME CONSUMING.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS NINETY
DAYS WITH THE ONE FORTY FIVE DAY
EXTENSION IN WHICH TO REVIEW
THESE TRANSACTIONS THAT'S A
FAIRLY QUICK REVIEW FOR
IMPORTANT PROCESS. IN THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS DOZENS IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF TRANSACTIONS
INVOLVING NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
HAVE PRECEDED MOST WITHOUT
CONTROVERSY MOST WITH CONDITIONS
THAT PROTECT CONSUMERS. WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN DO THAT
CANNOT BE DONE WITHOUT THIS
OVERSIGHT IS TO IMPOSE
ENFORCEABLE CONDITIONS KEEP
HOSPITALS OPEN AND EMERGENCY
ROOMS IN LABOR AND DELIVERY AND
MORE. YOU WILL ALSO HEAR FROM
THE OPPOSITION THAT SOMEHOW AB
TWENTY EIGHTY UNWINDS MANAGED
CARE IN ON DOES INTEGRATED
DELIVERY SYSTEMS NOTHING COULD
BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH
INTEGRATED DELIVERY SYSTEMS
WHETHER IT'S KAISER OR SUTTER OR
SHARP. INCLUDE A HEALTH PLAN AS
WELL AS A HOSPITAL SYSTEM SYSTEM
IN THE PHYSICIAN GROUP ALL OF
THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
HEALTH ACCESS HAS FOUGHT FOR.
TIMELY ACCESS NETWORK ADEQUACY
RATE REVIEW FISCAL SOLVENCY ON
AND ON OR IMPOSE ON THE HEALTH
PLAN WHICH THEN CONTRACTS WITH
THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN THE HOUSE
AND THE PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATION.
THOSE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS OR
THE ONES WE HOLD DEAR CREATING
AN INTEGRATED DELIVERY SYSTEM
WITHOUT THEM IS SOMETHING WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE FOR THOSE
REASONS WE'RE DELIGHTED TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHTY. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES GOOD
MORNING I CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT. FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHTY MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MALLEY I AM A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND ITS
AFFILIATES COMPRISING OF TWO
POINT ONE MILLION THAT UNION
MEMBERS AND THE STATE. HAVE
FOUGHT FOR DECADES TO CONTROL
THE RISING COST OF HEALTHCARE.
THE UNCONTROLLED COST OF CARE
HAS RESULTED IN SACRIFICES FOR
OUR MEMBERS. AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE WHO OFTENTIMES CHOOSE TO
FORGO HIGHER WAGES JUST TO
MAINTAIN THEIR HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE. FOUR
YEARS AGO THE U. F. C. W. AND
EMPLOYERS BENEFIT TRUST WHICH IS
THE HEALTH PLAN FOR- THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST THAT
SUTTER HEALTH. AFTER AN
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT THE
RAPID CONSOLIDATION AMONG
HOSPITALS PHYSICIANS AND NURSES
AND INSURERS IN CALIFORNIA LEAD
TO HIGHER COSTS AND IT'S DOCTOR
WOULD SAID IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS SUTTER HEALTH-
EVENTUALLY AGREED TO PAY. FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SETTLE THOSE CLAIMS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SHOULD HAVE EXTENDED
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OVER
NONPROFIT HOSPITAL MERGERS. AND
ALL HEALTH SYSTEM TRANSACTIONS
IN ORDER TO REVIEW THE IMPACT ON
QUALITY. COST AND ACCESS TO
NEEDED SERVICES. THIS IS
ESSENTIAL TO GETTING COSTS UNDER
CONTROL. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
HIGH PRICES FOR HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DRIVEN BY INDUSTRY
CONSOLIDATION AND ANTI
COMPETITIVE PRACTICES HAVE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED HEALTH
CARE PREMIUMS FOR EMPLOYERS
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES. THIS
HAS RESULTED IN LOWER WAGES FOR
WORKERS AND SLOWER JOB GROWTH.
IN OTHER WORDS AB TWENTY EIGHTY
IS NOT JUST HEALTHCARE BILL IT
IS THE WAGES AND JOB GROWTH BILL
. THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY IS
CROWDING OUT THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND WE
CAN'T LET THIS CONTINUE. WE NEED
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MAKE
HEALTH CARE MARKETS WORK THE WAY
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO RESULTING IN
LOWER PRICES A STRONGER ECONOMY
AND MORE AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. I THANK YOU
AND WE ALSO REQUEST YOUR BOTH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY EIGHTY
COME TO THE MICROPHONE AND WE'LL
BE TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT ONLY NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY HI KAREN MEMBERS BETH
NON OWSKI WITH SEIU STATE
COUNCIL. EVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS THEIR FAMILIES
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY EIGHTY TWO EIGHT.
TWO ZERO EIGHT ZERO WE'LL BE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT ONLY. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FAIR IN SUPPORT. WE WILL GO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AT THE BALLOT ARE
QUITE ON BEHALF OF NEW ROUTE
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA THE PART
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS KNOW AT
BOTTOM ALL WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ALEXANDRA LEN
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING ORINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN CUBA
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVED OPPOSITION I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST ESTABLISH A QUORUM STONE
HERE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES KALRA
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN REYES RIGHT
HERE RIVAS. LEE WICKS. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
COME UP.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BIRDS OF THE CABINET COMMITTEE
MY NAME STEEP MARK ROMAN I'M
WITH CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY. I WANT TOSPEAK
BRIEFLY TO THE VALUE OF
INTEGRATED NETWORKS HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS AND THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CARE- IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS TO FLEX RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT SPECIALTY CARE IS
AVAILABLE IN THOSE AREAS. VERY
CONCERNED THAT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE THAT HARDER
TO ACCOMPLISH. WANT TO SPEAK
VERY SPECIFICALLY TO- THE
EXPANDED AUTHORITY OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OVER HEALTHCARE
TRANSACTIONS NOT JUST HOSPITALS
BUT OHER SECTORS- UP OF THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD. I CONCERNS
THAT THERE ARE NOT DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS- THE BILL PROVIDES
FOR A PUBLIC HEARING VERY MUCH
LIKE THIS ONE WITH THERE IS
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. BUT IT'S NOT- HEARING
ON THE EVIDENCE THAT'S NOT THE
PRESENTATION OF EVIDENCE THE
ABILITY TO BE HEARD BEFORE THE-
REGULATOR MAKES A DECISION TO
RESPOND TO EVIDENCE TO PROVIDE
COUNTERVAILING EVIDENCE- IT'S A
COMPLETE DELEGATION OF
DISCRETION- TWO ONE INDIVIDUAL.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT VIOLATES DUE
PROCESS- IT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO RESPOND TO A
CHANGING HEALTH CARE ENVIRONMENT
WHEN THERE IS NOT CERTAINTY. IN
WHAT THE PROCESS IS GOING TO BE
AND WHAT KIND OF CONDITIONS ARE
GOING TO COME OUT. SO NOT ONLY
IS THERE THE TIMELINE HAS THIS
BEEN REFERENCED BY THE
SUPPORTERS OF NINETY DAYS THOSE
ARE ROUTINELY EXTENDED BECAUSE
THE REGULATOR REQUESTS MORE TIME
IN THE PARTICIPANT OF COURSE
AGREES TO EXTENDING MORE TIME
BECAUSE TO SAY NO WOULD MEAN
YOU'D GET A DENIAL. BUT THAT'S
NOT REALLY THE POINT THE CONCERN
IS THAT YEARS OF PLANNING DUE
DILIGENCE ANALYSIS IN A HOSPITAL
TRANSACTION OCCUR BEFORE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL PROCESS EVEN
STARTS. AND THE CHILLING EFFECT
THAT OCCURS WHEN ALL THAT EFFORT
IS PUT INTO- DEVELOPING A NEW- A
NEW HEALTH CARE MODEL A NEW
TRANSACTION THE NEW SYSTEM. AND
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY REASONS. CAN
SUMMARILY DENY IT AND THAT'S
HAPPENED BEFORE A TRANSACTION
HAS BEEN REJECTED BY A THREE
SENTENCE LETTER- SO VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THAT WILL
AFFECT HEALTH CARE THE
HEALTHCARE PROCESS GOING FORWARD
AND NOTING THAT A WRIT OF
MANDATE. IS NOT DUE PROCESS
BECAUSE THERE IS NO UNDERLYING
RECORD FOR THE APPEALS COURT TO
LOOK AT OTHER THAN ANALYSIS OF
THE KEY USE OF DISCRETION- WITH
THAT WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE HEARING WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY EIGHTY. MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESERVE THE COMMITTEE BRANDON
MARCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS MEGAN LOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION. JOHN
SINCLAIR ABOUT THE SCRIPTS
HEALTH IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JOHN
VALENCIA FOR VSP VISION CARE WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED UP
POSITION ON A TECHNICAL
SUBSTANTIVE MATTER WILL WORK ON
THE OFFICE WITH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY. EIGHTY AT THIS POINT WE
WILL NOT TAKE FOR THE TEST MONEY
BUT WE'LL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION.
AND OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. YOUR
FRIEND I'LL IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
THERE ARE FEW IN OPPOSITION. WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KELLY HAD ON BEHALF OF
BETTER HEALTH IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TYLER
ARE YOU ARE TO HAVE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. CUNAXA GO
TO LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU PRESS ONE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KATHLEEN SORIANO ON THE HOUSE
THE CAT MEDICINE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AND HOW WE GOT THEM
BALLOTS WITH KAISER PERMANENTE
PAY OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER I THANK
YOU A PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES
THEY WILL RIP BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT CNN DR TO
MAKE CLOTHES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY- I'M
TRYING TO CHECK. FOR SOMEONE
ELSE OF A- I'M SORRY THIS REALLY
. I'LL JUST BE. FULLER WOULD I
APPRECIATE YOUR WITH ME ABOUT
THIS BILL MORE I THINK THE
INTENT OF THE BILL'S GREAT WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO OPPOSE THE
CONSOLIDATION AND NATURAL
MONOPOLY OF A HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THAT IS A GOOD FOR PATIENTS OR
CONSUMERS I UNDERSTAND THAT MY
COUNTY SANTA CLARA HAS SOME
ISSUES AND I HOPE YOU COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE COUNTY IS IN
A CAR TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
UNIQUE SITUATION WHICH WE HAVE
PUBLICLY PROVIDED HEALTH ISN'T
HINDERED IN THIS BILL BUT I
THINK THAT IS YOUR ATTENTION SO
I. JUST HOPE YOU CAN GET TO WORK
ON THAT ISSUE. YES YOU HAVE MY
ASSURANCE MISTER LEE THAT WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY WORK ON THAT
ISSUE. ALL UP. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE I
MISSED THAT MR LEE SO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS BUT MAKE SURE
THE COMMITTEE HAS THE-
OPPORTUNITY SO ALL RIGHT SING
THAT. THEY MAKE US I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU I HOPE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE REALIZES MY
COMMITMENT TO RURAL HEALTH CARE
AND I AM THE LAST PERSON THE
WORLD WHO WOULD WANT TO DO
ANYTHING TO HARM. RURAL HEALTH
CARE. I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT- IN-
READ ALL THE RESPECT TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS INTRODUCED ABOUT AN
APPEAL PROCESS TO AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE THE
IDEA THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS THE LAST SAY IN THIS ISSUE
POTENTIALLY. IS NOT IT IS NOT
CORRECT- AND I WILL SAY YOU HAVE
TO I WILL SAY LOOK WE ARE OPEN
TO WORKING WITH ANYBODY WHO
COMES TO US WITH REASONABLE
CONCERNS THAT IS A HALLMARK. OF
THE WAY I DO BUSINESS IN MY
OFFICE. I'M DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR
JUST STRAIGHT OUT OPPOSITION.
FROM PEOPLE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THAT GIVES
US AN OPPORTUNITY WORK WITH
PEOPLE. STRAIGHT OPPOSITION.
IGNORES THE CHALLENGES WE FACE
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE HUGE PROBLEMS WITH. THE COST
OF HEALTH CARE THERE IS A HUGE
ISSUE HERE. AND WE MAY BE FACING
ANOTHER HUGE ISSUE COMING
FORWARD. THERE IS A POSSIBILITY
WE MAY LOSE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
FOR THE ACA. AND THOSE OF US
MEMBERS WHOHAVE BEEN LUCKY
RECENTLY TO BE ABLE TO NOT HEAR.
ABOUT RISING PREMIUMS FROM FROM
SOMEWHERE. IT CONSTITUENTS WHO
HAVE COVERAGE THROUGH THE ACA.
WE'LL HEAR IT AGAIN. IT'S OUR
DUTY TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
BEGIN TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND THE
COST OF HEALTHCARE THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO WE
SINCE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM I WILL
TAKE A MOTION THAT MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES KALRA
KILEY. KILEY NO MENTION. MENTION
I REYES. REYES AYE RIVAS. LEE
RIGHT THE AYE WICKS AYE WICKS
AYE. THAT NEEDS ONE MORE SO WILL
PUT OUT A CALL THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MEMBERS. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FOR MR
SANTIAGO IF WE COULD GET A
MESSAGE OVER TO HIM THAT. WE ARE
WAITING FOR HIM.
OKAY IN THE MEANTIME LET'S CATCH
UP ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY MISTER%
WOULD WE HAVE HEARD THAT BILL IT
IS SITTING ON CALL I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS. CUNNINGHAM I CAN. THAT
WAS HOUSE CORN THIS IS A VOTE ON
AB TWENTY EIGHTY. ADAM NUMBER
TWO. CUNNINGHAM NOW DAVIES KALRA
. KALRA AYE RIVAS. RIGHT THANK
YOU THE BILL IS OUT AND WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR MR SANTIAGO.
AT LEAST A RAVING BREATHING ARE
THIS GOOD SIZED. AS ALWAYS VERY
THIS I KNOW IT'S TOUGH MOVING
FROM. BUILDING TO BUILDING IT
HAS AND I NEEDED TO DO THAT I
PLEDGE MISTER NEEDED FOR THE
CORE BEFORE I COULD LEAVE. DOES
NOT HAVE THAT I UNDERSTAND WE'RE
JUST GIVING YOU GRIEF. HI MR
SANTIAGO WILL TAKE UP I DON'T
NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
TWO. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ALLOWS TO
PRESENT ON THIS AND I LIKE THIS
I THANK THE CHAIR. PERSONALLY
FOR HELPING US WITH THIS OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. I WOULD
SAY THAT THIS BILL HAS NOT IT
NOT AS AGGRESSIVE AS I WANTED TO
BE THE BEGINNING BUT IT BUT WHAT
IT DOES DO IS SHOW THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORKS- OVER
A NUMBER OF YEARS WE'VE CARED TO
BILLS TO CHANGE- LPS
CONSERVATORSHIP LAWS. LIKEWISE
WE ASK FOR STATE AUDITS AND THE-
COMMITTEE JURISDICTION HEALTH.
ALSO HELD HEARINGS- TO HELP US
WITH THIS WHAT WE DISCOVERED IS
THAT THAT TO SOME DEGREE THE FOR
THE SYSTEM DOES NEED FIXING I
LIKE TO SAY BROKEN SOME PEOPLE
LIKE TO SAY FIXING. AND SO WE
COME UP WITH A BILL THAT WE
THINK- STRIKES THE BALANCE TO
TRY TO HELP. OUR FOLKS WHO ARE
ON HOUSING AND HAVING SEVERE.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE CRISIS IS- WE
CALL THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
COORDINATION- ACT THAT WERE
PUSHING FOR TODAY WHAT DOES
BASICALLY TWO THINGS- IT ALLOWS
FOR A CARE COORDINATION PLAN TO
KERR AT THE STATE LEVEL AND AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS- INVOLVED INCLUDING
THOSE PLANS- IT CREATES A
REPORTING FRAMEWORK CURRENTLY
THERE ARE. NO MECHANISM FOR
REPORTING HOW THOSE DOLLARS ARE
USED WHO WAS HELP OR-
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ON. INDIVIDUALS
OR HELP. AND IN THREE ALLOWS FOR
MHA M. H. S. A. DOLLARS TO BE
USED. FOR THAT COORDINATED KERR-
IN I'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE
NUMBERS IT THAT SHOULD BE
ALARMING TO ANYONE. LET'S BACK
UP A SECOND SAY THAT. WHAT IT
WHAT IT WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
IS THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
WHO IS HELD- FOR EITHER A-
SEVENTY TWO HOURS. FIFTEEN DAYS
THIRTY DAYS OR A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS WHAT CHANGING ANY OF
THAT THOSE LAWS LAWS ALREADY
EXIST. THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE A
HEALTHCARE A MENTAL HEALTH CARE
COORDINATION PLAN. BEFORE THEY
RELEASED SIMPLY SO THAT THEY CAN
GET THE WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
SERVICES TO HELP THEM BE
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR LIVES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU SOME REALLY ALARMING
NUMBERS. ON WHEN WE TOOK A LOOK
AT THE AUDIT THAT WAS STRUCTURE
FROM TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AND L.
PICK ON IT LIKE I AM IN L. A.
COUNTY BUT THEY LOOK AT A COUPLE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES- OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT WERE HELD. 43000403%
OF THOSE PEOPLE I HAD MULTIPLE-
CYCLE THROUGH THE SAME SYSTEM
OUT OF OUT OF THAT TEN THOUSAND
OF THOSE PEOPLE ENTERED THE
SYSTEM AND LET THE SYSTEM OVER
TEN TIMES. THAT SYSTEM IS BROKEN
WHEN WE WHEN WE WENT WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO STREETS WHEN PEOPLE HELP THEY
SHOULD BE GETTING THE HELP THAT
THEY ABSOLUTELY NEED BUT THEY
HAVEN'T AND THAT'S WHAT THE
HEARING- THAT YOU HELP PUT
TOGETHER REVEALED THAT THEY NEED
TO BE A CORONATION PLANTS OF
BOOKS CAN GET THAT. THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED DURING THE TIME-
THE- THAT THEY'RE BEING HELD TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES- AND IN
FACT I'M GONNA GO OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD BUT IT WAS FIVE HUNDRED
THOSE PEOPLE WENT IN AND OUT OF
THE SYSTEM ABOUT SEVENTY TWO
TIMES. SO WE TAKE A TAKE A LOOK
AT A SYSTEM THAT IS BROKEN WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
WITH IT- MISTER TERRY. YOU GIVE
ME A LITTLE BIT LONGER THAN I
PROBABLY DESERVE BEING LATE TO
THE- TO PRESENT- BUT ALSO MUCH
SHORTER THAN HAVE BEEN THE CASE
I'D LIKE TO MAKE ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT A SYSTEM THAT IS NOT
HELPING. OTHER PEOPLE WHO NEED
THEM THE MOST- TODAY- THOSE-
THOSE OF OUR NEIGHBORS WERE
ANNOUNCED. AND HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE- OF ISSUES AND WE'RE
JUST NOT PROVIDING THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED. SO I WE THINK
THAT THIS IS. A MODEST BUT STILL
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
IMPACT ON THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO
ARE ALL TRYING TO HELP. BIGGEST
FEATURE. THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS IS NOT THE
SPONSORED SO THERE ARE NONE.
OKAY THAT IS FINE. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU AND IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR. AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY TWO. I HATE SEEING
NONE ARE PRETTY WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY TWO. IF YOU IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FEAR IN SUPPORT.
MISTER JERRY HAVE NO SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU IS THERE OPPOSITION.
OKAY SO WAY. WE HAVE THE TECH
FOLKS COMING FORWARD SO WE'LL
TAKE A POSITION IN THE HEARING
ROOM FIRST AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
DEBRA FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WHO'S WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE SO GO AHEAD PLEASE
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RUNNING
TO GO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION-
BEFORE AGAIN LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE- AND THE
COMMITTEES FOR WORKING WITH US-
INCLUDING THE MOST RECENT ASCENT
OF AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN SO
WE REALLY DO. APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
DOING UNFORTUNATELY WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION- BUT LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR- AS BE FIGHTING THE
PROPOSAL SO WITH THAT- ROUTE-
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION OR COLLABORATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU RIGHT
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE DEBORAH
THIRD DEBORAH AUTHOR YOU WITH US
. YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SENATE ROTH WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY
WE DO STILL OPPOSE THIS BILL
WILL BE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT MR SANTIAGO HAS
MADE. BUT RESPOND TO CONCERNS WE
HAVE RAISED INCLUDING THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS. ABOUT UNNECESSARY
EXTENSIONS OF INVOLUNTARY HOLDS
PENDING DISCHARGE PLANNING.
UNFORTUNATELY WE OPPOSE THE USE
OF AN HSA FUNDS TO PAY FOR
LOCKED. BOND TERRY TREATMENT. WE
DO SUPPORT IMPROVEMENTS TO
DISCHARGE PLANNING. WE BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO REDUCE BE
REVIVING DOOR HOSPITALIZATION.
HOWEVER AFFECTED DISCHARGE
PLANNING DEPENDS ON THE ACTUAL
AVAILABILITY. OF A RANGE OF
SERVICES. TO MAKE THIS CHARGE
PLANNING MEETING. OUR CONCERN.
IF THIS BILL ABA ON ACCOUNT
HOSPITAL AND PAYERS TO CREATE
THIS CHARGE PLANNED SERVICES
THAT DO NOT EXIST AT THE
NECESSARY SCALE. THE RECENT DH
CS ASSESSMENT OF CALIFORNIANS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
SHOWS MANY IMPORTANT SERVICES
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO EFFECTIVE
DISCHARGE PLANNING FOR LACKING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. INCLUDING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES HERE
SUPPORT SERVICES EVIDENCE BASED
OUTPATIENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES SUCH AS THE THIRD OF
COMMUNITY TREATMENT. ISIS RATHER
TRANSITIONAL RESIDENTIAL AND
LONG TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT AS WELL SO
BEFORE PLACING MANDATE FROM
HOSPITAL COUNTY'S IMPAIRS THE
STATE MUST TAKE STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT THESE CRITICAL SERVICES
YES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH PROJECT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU. RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OAK ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FEAR IN OPPOSITION. WE
WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO TERRY
MEMBER EVER SHE'D WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ON BEHALF O THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE IRVINE COUNTY
THE CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND OPPOSITION ALSO I CONVENE
OPPOSITION FROM THE RACIAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT A LITTLE LINE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
MATTHEW GALLAGHER ON THE APRICOT
BOYCE'S THE RAINY WE REMAINING
OPPOSED WHAT MEDITATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE-
COMMITTEE SANTIAGO ONE THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US AND TAKING
SOME OF THE- WE'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK THE WAY THAT.
THAT THIS BILL IS DEALING WITH
THE DISCHARGE PLAN IS REALLY
VERY. IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
DEALING WITH- JUST A COUPLE OF
OTHER NOTES ONE OF THE THINGS
THOUGH THAT THEY THEY HEARING
THAT WE HELD IN CONJUNCTION WITH
HEALTH COMMITTEE. SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO REALLY SHOWED WAS THE LACK
OF DATA INTO ANY CHANGES TO THE. THE ACTOR SAID THE LANDER MEN
FEATURES SHORT ACT. IT ARE HARD
TO FOR US I THINK TO BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY UNTIL WE ULTIMATELY GET
GET THAT DATA AND THE PART OF
THIS BILL THAT I AM. STRUGGLING
WITH ALTHOUGH IT'S TECHNICALLY
OUTSIDE THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT REALLY WHAT THE BEST
WAY TO DO IT IS ARE THE M. HSA
FUNDS. INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT HAS
IT IN IN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DAHLE VOLUNTARY TREATMENT IN THE
WHOLE CARE CORE PROPOSAL THAT
MIGHT INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT
REALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA'S NOT
PROVIDED. THE RIGHT KINDS OF
TREATMENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND SO NOW WE'RE STUCK WITH
TALKING ABOUT DO WE BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN. ACCESSING
THESE THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
AND SORT OF IN AND OUT AND IN
AND OUT A LOT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING US FOR THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED. THAT'S PART OF WHY
THEY'RE IN AND OUT. OF THIS THE
PROGRAMS BUT GOING TO
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT. WHICH HAS
BEEN DEMONSTRATED IS NOT
EFFECTIVE AND CAN OFTENTIMES
EXACERBATE THE CONDITION THE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS LIKE
THESE PEOPLE FACE. IS A PART
THAT I REALLY STRUGGLE WITH AND
EXTENDING M. HSA FUNDS TO
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT WHICH IS
CLEARLY WHAT IS NOT DESIGNED TO
DO AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. IS SOMETHING THAT I
DEFINITELY STRUGGLE WITH IT IS
TECHNICALLY A QUESTION NOW FOR
APPROACH TO DEAL WITH IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT HEALTH COMMITTEE.
REALLY DIDN'T. I DIDN'T ADDRESS
AN APPROPRIATE WAY IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WITH TECHNICALLY
WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION I'M JUST
RAISING THAT BECAUSE THAT DOES
IS SOMETHING THAT GIVES ME SOME
HARPER AND THAT'S- THE HEART OF
A LOT OF THE OPPOSITION. THAT
BEING SAID I THINK FOR ME THIS
BILL. IS FINE TO PASS OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THE EVEN GIVEN
THAT PARTICULAR CHALLENGE AND
I'M HOPING THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHICH-IS AN APPROPRIATE PLACE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT HOW FUNDS OUT OF
IMAGES THEY ARE OR ARE NOT BEING
SPENT. WE'LL TAKE TAKE A SERIOUS
LOOK AT IT SAID THIS IS. THAT'S
MY CONCERN WITH THIS THAT THAT'S
MY CHALLENGE FOR THIS ALTHOUGH I
THINK AND WE'VE WORKED THROUGH
THIS QUITE A BIT WE'RE GOING TO
BE SEEING THE CARE COURT
PROPOSALS COMING- FROM THE
SENATE WE'RE VERY MUCH AS A
COMMITTEE INVOLVED IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. BECAUSE OF THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO PEOPLE'S
CIVIL LIBERTIES THAT'S THE MAIN
CORE OF WHAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO BE IS GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT. SO I THINK THIS IS.
FILE ITEM HOPING WE DO PASS THIS
BILL OUT TODAY I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT ONE CONCERN THAT I
THINK WE STILL. NEED TO BE
WORKING ON. MAY I RESPOND AS JR.
I'M SURE BY YOU CAN RESPOND
IN YOUR CLOSE TO WHAT WHEN
THINGS I WANNA DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT MEMBERS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS
GET QUESTIONS MISS CUNNINGHAM.
YEAH I'LL I'LL TRY TO BE FAIRLY
BRIEF BECAUSE- MR MENTIONS THE
GRAMMYS HE'S GOT A FLIGHT TO
CATCH. UP I JUST WANT TO OFFER
SOME ANECDOTAL EXPERIENCE FROM
MY OWN COUNTY MY LAW PRACTICE.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT PEOPLE ARE
CYCLING IN OUR SYSTEM- THAT IN
MY EXPERIENCE S A 100% CORRECT.
THEY GO BACK THEY GET RELEASED
AFTER THEIR SEVEN TWO HOURS OR
WHATEVER THE HELL HOLE THIS.
THEY CALMLY THERE GO BACK THE
STREETS. THEY GO BACK TO
ENCAMPMENTS. OR THE GO BACK TO
THEIR FAMILIES. AND THEY ARE IN
FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN. IN MY LAW
PRACTICE. WHICH IN THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO THEY GET RELEASED
TO WHEREVER THEY WERE. AND THEY
DON'T END UP BACK IN THE SYSTEM
UNTIL. THEY COMMIT A CRIME. AND
THEN YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DEAL WITH THE SITUATION
WHICH IS REALLY AT ITS CORE IN A
LOT OF THESE CASES A MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM. A SCHIZOPHRENIC
THAT'S OFF THE MEDICATION WHAT
HAVE YOU- IN. THE CONTEXT OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH
IS- SHALL WE SAY COULD USE
IMPROVEMENT AND HOW IT HANDLES
THESE CASES. TO PUT IT MILDLY-
SO THE CYCLING'S RAIL AND- IF I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE BILLS TRY
TO CORRECTLY YOU WANT TO MAKE IT
SO THAT WHEN THEY GET RELEASED.
THERE'S SOME SORT OF TREATMENT
PLAN DO I HAVE THAT RIGHT
CORRECT AND I AND I GET THE
BURDENS ON THAT AND I GET THIS
COULD BE DONE A TIGHT TIMELINE
ALL THAT. BUT THEY ARE COMMONLY
FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN AT LEAST IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY THEY'RE
NOT RELEASE WITH ANY KIND BUT
ALL. DIRT GIVEN WHATEVER MINIMAL
TREATMENT THEY THEY- IS DEEMED
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCE DURING THE WHOLE.
AND THEN THEY'RE SENT BACK TO
THEIR FAMILIES ARE SENT BACK TO
WORK. TO THE STREETS ARE SENT
BACK TO THE ENCAMPMENTS. AND-
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE SO MANY
PEOPLE I THINK CYCLING. IN AND
OUT SO I AM IN SUPPORT THE BILL
THE DAY. THAT I. IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT PAYMENT
THING IS ABOVE MY PAY GRADE ALL
THE PROBES FIGURE THAT OUT. BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT STAFF ON
ME AT LEAST OF THERE'S A PLAN
THERE'S SOMETHING. THAT I MEAN
IF NOTHING ELSE A FAMILY MEMBER.
CAN LOOK AT THAT AND GO OKAY.
THIS IS THE MEDICATION THEY WERE
ON THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE OFF THIS
IS WHAT A PROFESSIONAL IS SAYING
THEY NEED. I CAN HOPEFULLY HELP
GET THEM TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
ARE ACCEPTING OF THAT TREATMENT
VOLUNTARILY. IT GIVES IT GIVES
THEM A FIGHTING CHANCE I THINK
SO THANKS FOR CURRENT BILL. ALL
RIGHT THIS RACE THE MISTER KALRA
. THANK YOU MR THANK. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM THE
CHAIR- THAT'S WHAT I STRUGGLE
WITH ALSO AND WHEN I HEAR THE
OPPOSITION PEOPLE THAT WE TRUST
PEOPLE THAT WE THAT WOULD THAT
ARE OUR ALLIES WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO PROTECT THOSE CIVIL
LIBERTIES. BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THE
SPACE AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO TRY
TO FIND SOLUTIONS AND THIS IS
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE.
POSSIBILITIES FINDING THAT
BALANCE BETWEEN TAKING CARE OF
SOMEONE IN A VERY HUMANE WAY BUT
ALSO PROTECTING THEIR CIVIL
LIBERTIES SO THAT WE DON'T
OVERSTEP ON EITHER SIDE. AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE HEADED IN THAT
DIRECTION AND I. I APPRECIATE
THAT A FROM YOU AND I TOO WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW IT
PROGRESSES. IN PROTECTING CIVIL
LIBERTIES ALSO TREATING THOSE
WITH. IT TREATABLE AND ALMOST
UNTREATABLE- MENTAL ILLNESSES IN
THE MOST HUMANE WAY POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA THE
NETWORKS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I LINE MY EXPERIENCE IS
CERTAINLY WITH THE SUMMER
CUNNINGHAM- MOVED WHEN I WAS
WORKING PUBLIC DEFENDER AND
APPEARING MANY TIMES BEFORE A
LEGEND- DOCK- JUDGE MANLEY- AND
HIS- MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COURT OF AB OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COURT- TREATMENT COURT-
AND HOW HARD IT WAS. TO BUT WHAT
WHEN TO KEEP SOMEONE ON A PLAN-
WHEN YOU LOSE TRACK OF THEM OR
THERE ISN'T A PLAN OR THERE IS
STRICT MONITORING- THAT OCCURS-
I ALSO SHARE A LINE MY CONCERNS
WITH THE CHAIR- IN TERMS OF. THE
OF THE FUNDS ARE BEING USED- FOR
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT HOWEVER-
GIVEN THE FACT THAT- YOU- BUT AS
THE AUTHOR IN GETTING YOUR
SINCERITY ON THIS ISSUE AND THE
FACT YOU'VE ALREADY TAKEN
AMENDMENTS AT ABOUT A LATE SOME-OF THE CONCERNS. OF THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER FOLKS THAT- THAT EXPRESSED
CONCERNS I'M CONFIDENT THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK IN IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION ON THIS AND-
I'M IM HAPPY TO VOTE FOR TODAY
WILL CONTINUE TO. ATTRACT MY
TRIP BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
SINCERE CONCERN- ON THE AND WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. DOESN'T TAKE ON
PROBABLY ONE THE TOUGHEST ISSUES
RIGHT NOW FACING OUR
<c.green>OMMUNITIES- I WAS AS HOUSING</c>
CHAIR ON A CALL WITH THEM A LOT
OF THE BIG CITY MAYORS WHO. THE
WHOLE CONVERSATION FOR AN HOUR
WAS ON THIS TOPIC- AND I THINK
WE ALL STRUGGLE WITH WHAT WE DO
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO HERE- AND- I ABSOLUTE OR
SEND THE CONCERNS BUT I. DON'T
WANT TO SEE THE CONVERSATION
MOVED FORWARD. I'M IN OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S WEIGHING IN THERE'S A
LOT OF CONVERSATION ON THIS I
DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE THE RIGHT
ANSWER BUT WHAT I DO KNOW IS THE
STATUS QUO IS NOT WORKING. AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO BRING FORTH IDEAS TO
KEEP PUSHING. AND HAVING SOMEONE
COMFORTABLE CALM CONVERSATIONS
AND SO IN THAT SENSE I'M- HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THAT I AM
HAPPY TO ALSO BE A THOUGHT
PARTNER WITH YOU ON THIS IS THIS
MOVES FORWARD BUT- IT'S A TOUGH
ONE SO THANK YOU FOR TAKING IT
ON. THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT CNN SANTIAGO
YOU MAY CLOSER AND LOOK THIS IS
A HEALTHY DEBATE THAT I THINK
YOU KNOW THE CONVERSATION ABOUT-
AND ACCESS AND HOW WE GET THIS
WRONG RIGHT AT THE M. H. S. A.
DOLLARS NOW SAVE A FIVE PER
SECOND HOW YOU MAY FEEL ABOUT
THE DEBATE ON THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE OF DOLLARS. BUT IT IS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROGNOSTICATORS FOR
THAT THAT THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT
DEBATE AND WE PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE THAT DEBATE THE REASON WE
ARGUED AT THE TIME I'M GONNA GO
BY MEMORY SO IF SOMEBODY SAYS
I'M ABOUT A COUPLE OF DOLLARS
OFF- I'M HAPPY TO CORRECTED
ONLINE BUT WHEN WE LOOKED AT
WHEN WE ASK FOR THE AUDIT WE ARE
NOT EXPECTING TO FIND CERTAIN
THINGS. THAT WE DID DURING THAT
TIME IN AT THE TIME WE FOUND
THAT L. A. COUNTY HAD CLOSE TO A
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE FUNDS NOW
WHEN THEY'RE AT THE TIME WAS I
THINK A HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE LIVING ON THE STREETS- IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK IT WAS
SIXTY THREE OR SIXTY FIVE THE
TIME AGAIN I SAID I'M FUDGING
THE NUMBERS A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
I REMEMBER EXACTLY BUT WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT NUMBERS LIKE THAT
PEOPLE LIVING ON THE STREETS AND
YOU SEE. CLOSE TO A BILLION
DOLLARS- IN A BANK ACCOUNT YEAH
IT'S TIME TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE DOLLARS IN USE IN A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY THAT'S OUR
PRODUCT THAT WE SHOULD DO SO BUT
BUT I THINK IT'LL I THINK IT'S
BEEN SAID IT AT ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY SAID
INSTEAD OF TOLD NOT WORKING I
DON'T KNOW ANYBODY'S GONNA ARGUE
THAT THAT WHAT THAT THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING ON
HOMELESSNESS. IS AS EFFECTIVE IS
IT SHOULD BE DAHLE ELEMENTS OF
IT THAT WORK VERY WELL OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT WE NEED REVIEWS IT
DO DIFFERENTLY AND THEN THERE
ARE ELEMENTS OF IT IT JUST
BROKEN I MEAN WE'VE WE'VE
CREATED A VERY GOOD PROGRAMS BUT
WE ALSO CREATED BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS OF THE NIGHTMARES THAT
HAVE RESULTED IN RESULTS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
THE DEBATE IS NOT ABOUT CIVIL
LIBERTIES. IT'S NOT. MUCH ANY
OF. LAWS I'D LIKE TO STEP INTO
SOME THOSE CASES IN CERTAIN.
CASES I WOULD. BUT THE BUT THE
BIG TODAY IS ABOUT. CREATE A
VERY SIMPLE COORDINATED PLAN AT
THE STATE LEVEL. A VERY SIMPLE
COORDINATED PLAN OF THE COUNTY.
N. REPORTING MECHANISM BECAUSE
IT NO REPORTING IS DONE ON THIS.
THAT THAT SATISFIES- OUR QUEST
FOR DATA TO CHANGE THE LARGER
CONVERSATION AND LAWS. AND YES
THE DEBATE IS ABOUT USING THESE
DOLLARS DIFFERENTLY- WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND I THINK WE
BEGAN TO TALK TO SOME OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEES BUT THE TAKE A
LOOK AT HOW MUCH OF THESE
DOLLARS. ARE REALLY BEING HELD
IN FROM THESE ACCOUNTS. AND YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF IS IT GOOD
USE. OF THOSE DOLLARS TO BE HELD
IN THOSE ACCOUNTS WHEN PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING ON THE STREETS.
THE LPS LAWS THAT WERE SET IN
PLACE I SUPPORT FOR VERY GOOD
REASONS BECAUSE SERVICE APPLAUSE
OR SOME PLACE I SUPPORT VERY
GOOD REASONS BUT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT PLACES AND SPACES.
WHAT WE HAVE TO I WOULD ARGUE WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MAYBE
IT NEEDS TO CHANGE THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY BUT JUST
BECAUSE PEOPLE BROUGHT UP ALL
FATE. WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT A
PERSON WHO WAS HURT ON THE
STREETS. WE TAKE A LOOK AT A
PERSON WAS A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR DANGER TO OTHERS.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT A PERSON. WHO
IS. PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY.
N. AND MENTAL ANGUISH ON THE
STREETS. AND THEY CANNOT
DETERMINE FOR THEMSELVES TO GO
GET CARE. WHAT IS THE HUMANE
THING TO DO AND WHAT IS OUR MORE
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THAT IS TO
PROVIDE THAT PERSON HELP. AND SO
SHOULD WE HAVE TO CHANGE SOME OF
THE LOCAL AUTHORED BY OPAL
PEOPLE ABSOLUTELY. AND FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARGUE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T I INVITE THEM TO SKID
ROW TO TAKE A LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN AGONY. BLIT THE BLEEDING
. WHAT THE WHAT UNIMAGINABLE
PAINS AND IF THIS IS A LUCIEN IS
LET'S GO ASK THEM IF THEY NEED
HELP. AND THEY SAY NO AND WALK
AWAY BECAUSE WE'VE DONE OUR JOB
SOMETHING IS VERY BROKEN ABOUT
ALL. ABOUT US OUR MORAL
COMPASSES IN THE WAY THAT WE DO
THIS WORK. THAT'S NOT THE BIG
TODAY. BUT IT SHOULD BE SAID BUT
THE DEBATE TODAY IS A
COORDINATED PLAN FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL BEFORE THEY LEAVE.
REPORTING ON WHETHER IT'S
WORKING OR NOT IN USING DOLLARS
THAT ARE THERE TO HELP THOSE WHO
ARE MOST IN NEED THAT'S WHAT THE
DEBATE IS THAT AND THAT'S WHAT
HOPING. TO MOVE FORWARD- IN AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
THANK MISTER. THANK YOU MR
SANTIAGO WELL TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOST IN A
SECOND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STAND BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
. DAVIES I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES. REYES I RIVAS. RIVAS
HI LI LI I WICKS WEEKS I. THANK
YOU THE BILL IS OUT LET'S GO
CATCH THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON AB
TWENTY EIGHTY OUR ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS OUT BUT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DAVIES DAVIES NO RIVAS
RIVAS I. GREAT I. IS THIS KILEY
COMING BACK. FIVE THAT'S FINE
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU ALL FOR A
LATE HEARING IN A LONG DAY AND
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS.